Jay Bilas there sure is bilis you've
seen dandaka jizz game haven't you yeah
I saw in college briefly I didn't spend
a whole lot of time breaking his game
well he's called out the couple of the
Danette saying for the love of God
nobody else gets to shoot on camera
except for you Dan because McLovin and
Seaton were taking some jumpers there so
you saw McLovin shoot if you had a
shooting contest between McLovin and
dockage who you got yeah I think it's
really a coin flip Dan athletically it
is it is a stunningly fair fight all
right that's it Jay that's all we wanted
to talk to you about that's pretty much
all I've got anyway all right what
should I be watching for it to combine
well I mean I think it's like anything
else Dan you'll see guys at the combine
that'll just stick out to you and stand
out it's almost like watching when you
go to like a high school AAU thing where
you go wait a minute that guy is
different and there are a few guys that
really stood out to me yesterday and
I've seen all of them but but Melvin
Frazier tulane really stood out with his
he's a 6 7 Wing with his length and his
ability to guard people and he's so
athletic his offensive game is not as
good as his defensive game but he can
get to the rim and he can make an open
shot he needs to be more consistent and
then I thought Dante D Vincenzo stood
out in a big way yesterday and I'd be
surprised honestly if he plays again
today frankly I'd advise that he didn't
that he didn't play but he's a he's a
first-round pick I think you saw out
there you know several guys three four
maybe five guys that could very well be
first-round picks even Javon carter
stood out the guy who played four years
and put together a really impressive
body of work and you think okay we know
who he is but he really stood out with
you know just how relentless he is
defensively and you know it'll make a
team just because of that that you can
put him he can he can affect the game
but I just put him on the ball and he's
gonna he's gonna impact things I still
every time
and we've all done this where you play a
game and then all of a sudden you
realize like that guy doesn't run fast
or jump high or quick or anything but
he's just good like just there are those
guys where you they kind of defy logic
but so how do you assess that it's thing
that they have where you go he just
somehow they make it work when they're
on the basketball floor but if you had
him do drills you probably wouldn't even
you know notice them yeah that's a good
question I mean five-on-five is really
where everything sticks out I mean I
remember years ago you know I played in
college with with chip Engelland who's
now with the San Antonio Spurs and one
of the best shooting coaches if not the
best in the game and when when Corey
Maggette II came out at Duke I think it
was a 99 he was a freshman and and and
he was not maybe not as skilled at that
age as he would be later
and so workouts might be might be an
issue where you get into something
you're not shooting it well and so so
chip told them that you know when if
you're gonna work out you're not
shooting and well things aren't going
right take a quick break and leave your
gym bag right in front of all the scouts
that are sitting in the stands to the
left or right whatever was he says and
go over and just take your shirt off and
because maguet ease was a Greek god with
this build and you know so you see
people in this testing and in how
athletic they are and you can kind of
get too seduced by out their athleticism
but if you don't see it in the 5 on 5
you have to be a little bit careful with
that and like you were saying guys that
can just play one of those guys is
Jerome Robinson coming out of Boston
College like he's a really complete
player he's not playing at this thing
because I think he's gonna be a
first-round pick but he's a really he's
a complete player that may not
athletically wow yeah but he gets out a
five-on-five game and he will he will
not wash out with a leak he will find a
place for a long time there if you're
the son's GM who are you taking I would
take DeAndre Aiden but you know I mean
just being completely Frank with you
like I don't I think I still err on the
side of super athletic big guys
and maybe that's the wrong way to look
at it or you know I don't want to
squeeze out somebody that like Don Shh
Luca Tanja Chu is a is a great passer
and the ball moves when he's in there
and he's really good off-screen roles
he's just he's not the the freaky
athlete that that Aten is but I just
think Aidan's one of these prototype big
guys that can step away and shoot it and
but he's not a he's not a big-time shot
blocker he can block shots but he
doesn't you know he's not like a guy's
gonna block five a game or something
like that like mo Bamba is or cheran
Jackson junior guys like that but I tend
to err with the big guys maybe I'm just
biased that way but do you think that
Don Chuck is sort of playing a power
hand here by saying you know I don't
know if I'm gonna leave Real Madrid and
go to the NBA and if he's going number
one he's coming over but if the sun's
all of a sudden take DeAndre Aten he
doesn't want to go to Sacramento do you
think that's the power play that's going
on it could be I don't really know the
answer to that I think it's just sort of
a leverage thing they're about to start
the Euro Final Four it Belgrade I think
in the next day or two
so he's mostly focused on that but you
know he's got a relationship with with
the new Phoenix coach Igor konashenkov
and so maybe maybe it's just the idea of
getting a promise from Phoenix at number
one so he knows what's going on but he
could still even if he gets drafted by
just for argument's sake by Sacramento
number two and he doesn't want to go
there he doesn't have to do that he can
still use leverage after the draft and
stay overseas Sacramento would key
whoever drops and will keep his rights
but but if you know if you're going to
park yourself overseas and they may you
may be able to force a trade I don't
think it's it's quite the same as like
John Elway when he said he's gonna play
baseball and what was 83 because back
then I think if you and I think the
rules were the same damn PA where if you
didn't play the sport for a year you
went that you'd go back in the draft but
when somebody takes you they've got your
rights for I don't even know what's a
period of time is but it but it's a
significant period talking to Jay Bilas
from the mothership the NBA combine on
ESPN the ACC wants to expand March
Madness to 72 teams your
reaction is a bunch of the ACC coaches
have talked about the fact that know
everybody and their brother in football
gets to play in a bowl game but only 68
teams go to the tournament and there's
still especially with some of the older
coaches something that in the back of
their minds that if they don't get to
the term and they get fired and you know
any ACC team is good enough just to get
in they're good enough to go to the
Final Four because Syracuse did it a
couple years ago that kind of thing and
there may be some truth to the the fact
that a bunch of teams in the league
could go to the Final Four and make a
run in the tournament but like I just
don't believe 72 would make any
difference from 68 I think if you're in
the first for that thing in Dayton
you're gonna get fired anyway it's not
that big a deal and to me I mean maybe
maybe look maybe this indicates I'm an
elitist but I don't really believe the
tournament starts until the first
Thursday when you get to the 60 14
bracket because if they are still trying
to convince everybody that these games
whether they're for games or what would
be eight games are they're not playing
games you know that we need to calm
opening-round games they're not opening
round games they're playing games that
would mean that would mean we have to
believe that eight teams are playing in
the opening round and 60 teams get a bye
you know that that just doesn't make any
any rational sense nobody looks at it
that way and it's more n-c-double-a
nonsense I whether it's 72 or 68 it's
the same thing the tournament doesn't
start till Thursday for the overwhelming
majority of people that are consuming
the product how do you solve the mystery
that is Michael Porter jr. he came out
and said he's the best player in the
draft which great I mean I kind of have
to go back to his high school days to
look at his game film but Michel
Porter's you know he's that that size
that ability is sort of the future of
the NBA but how good is he I don't know
and I think he's the most but I think
he's the most intriguing decision in the
draft and you know he was on our set
yesterday and had a great answer to the
question about his injury in his back
surgery he said it was a blessing
because he was in pain and he wasn't the
same player for a long period of time
even before he had the surgery and so he
kind of planned
in my head with that answer and I don't
know whether it's his answers agent mark
bartilson it doesn't matter it was a
great answer but I started thinking
about wait a minute you know when I
question some of the things about him as
a high school when he was in high school
was he injured then and and so I thought
that was a great great way to put it but
you know he was a guy that could have
been the first pick if he had come out
of high school he's that kind of talent
I did question along with other people
you know is he is he how tough is he but
but skill wise and ability wise all the
measurables he's he's really really
talented and at some point in the draft
you know with the the back injury and
the surgery or not at some point even
with that you're gonna say it's worth
the risk here I don't think you say that
at 1 2 or 3 because of just how good
these other guys are without any any
questions about health but you get to
the fifth pick or maybe the six or
something then you go and you know what
it's he's worth the risk there but you
got to get something for a top pick you
can't I don't think you can take any
risk with health your doctors I'd better
tell you that that there are no red
flags with regard to before I let you go
first time you saw James Harden play
what did you think he was an Arizona
State and I thought he was really good
but you know when I would say Danna it's
so hard like when you're looking back on
these things I used to see Steph Curry
play in high school and and if you had
told me when he was in high school that
he was gonna play in the NBA I was like
come on man he's kidding and and let
alone a MVP and kind of similar with
Harden like I kind of I thought he'd
play in the NBA and be a good player
when I first saw him was I thinking okay
there's a future MVP hall-of-famer I
didn't think I didn't think about it
that way and I don't know whether that's
good or bad honestly whether you have to
have it proven to you or something like
that I mean maybe that's the right way
to look at I have no idea all I know is
the more I watch this stuff I was way
more confident ten twelve years ago and
what I thought that I am now I don't
know you know you have certain beliefs
but but you know you I still I still
keep my mistake
what I thought about somebody years ago
at the forefront of my mind when I'm
looking at somebody else cuz you're
you're thinking hey man don't don't
don't judge too quickly you know there's
some guys you know you see LeBron you
know I mean you knew when he was in high
school I mean I remember when when he
was in high school I had said on a high
school week we broadcast this high
school game it sounds crazy back when we
did it but I said he's the best high
school player I've ever seen I got
criticized for it and it's like no this
guy is the real thing but but you know
some of the other guys you know you
don't want to dismiss to eat too quickly
so somebody that you're saying well I
don't think he's like good and all that
stuff you got a peak at least I feel
like I have to be careful with that
who did you with on what's what's the
biggest whiff where you look back and
it's always there in the forefront when
you're when you're sizing up these
players biggest whiff was back when and
there were a number of whiffs but the
biggest one was back when I was still
dubious of how good high school players
were gonna be and and when I was not
sure athleticism could carry the day
over skill and when I was not sure that
Dwight Howard should be the number one
pick over a mecca okhla for and you look
back and then what was I smoking and if
could I get some more now because he was
so ridiculously athletic but I thought
well you know his skill levels not there
and all that stuff and in your gun it
doesn't matter like his ridiculous
athleticism is going to trump all that
and I kind of I kind of was biased
against the high school players because
they hadn't proven anything yet
instead of looking at the raw the raw
ability level and now I'm exactly the
opposite now I don't I don't want to
hear all my college friends talk about
well what is this guy done and how can
we make a freshman player here I've made
that mistake these guys you know these
guys are talented and they're for real
and to pretend otherwise with an old
school and an old school mindset back
then and and that has been that's been
beaten out of me
I remember being around Steve Nash's
agent and he said he you know he's gonna
be a star and I I went we're like wait
really
and he goes oh my god people are gonna
love playing with this guy and I
remember watching him in college
Santa Clara and I went by it's a nice
little story and you know he seems you
know he's like energizing buddy and
frenetic pace and a whole bit and then
all of a sudden next thing I know I'm at
an all-star game and in Nash's agent
comes up and goes I remember I told you
Steve who's gonna be really good I said
yeah I remember that Billy I remember
that Bill Duffy well agents agents
always say their players are their stars
but but it doesn't mean they're not
right when they say it but you know it's
hard to and and look it goes the other
way too they're a bunch guys that I
thought would be stars and didn't turn
out as good as I thought and you know
they're they're like I didn't think I
didn't think Anthony Bennett should have
been the first pick of the Cavs several
years ago I remember the year was but I
didn't think that was the right choice I
didn't think that dudes gonna wash out
either if he's been taking a number five
I would have said yeah you know it's a
really good player I mean I watch to
play it you know be did I think that
dude was gonna wash out of the league
completely no way the one though I'll
tell you that that still I have not
changed my mind on even though it didn't
work out was Greg out that if Greg Oden
had been healthy and there was no
indication that he was not going to be
healthy when he was drafted I wouldn't I
still would take him number one because
I think he was going to be great and and
that's even including Durant knowing
Victor and would because I I mean I said
that draft night Durant's gonna lead the
league in scoring multiple times he's
gonna be a great player I just thought
Oden was it was the better choice and I
know you would take if Odin was healthy
that you you would still look at him as
a long-term investment better than Duran
yes I would and and you know even though
the game I mean right now maybe to be a
little bit different because the game
has changed a little bit you know we're
still that was back in 2007 if I
remember right but but you know there
the game has changed a little bit and
evolve so maybe if you're doing the
decision with those two guys at age 18
today in today's game maybe you're the
dynamic would be a little bit different
I need to think about that but I really
I really would be interested as to how
many GM's if they had the first pick
back in O seven would have taken Durant
number
want you know that's kind of the beauty
like the difficulty of being a GM
obviously is you are stuck with whatever
pick you making it and it but but at the
hard part for you know the rest of us
even though we're not you know it's it's
obviously more difficult being a GM but
we have to like you and I have to a pine
on every player so we're stuck with with
our thoughts on every player they're
only stuck with you know the future with
with who they drafted but you know what
was us it's not a big deal where will
will survive a man that's a hot take you
just dropped on it's a white hottie on a
Friday with twenty minutes left to go on
the show that's a hot take you just drop
there Steven Naismith you said oh my god
that's why I'd like to and I'm gonna
come up with my mock my mock shooters
list of who are the best shooters in the
Danette versus dandaka I can take
dockage I'm not worried about that but i
i'm i think McLovin might be able to
outshoot dockage and seaton is sneaky
good so I think that there's three of us
in this room that can outshoot dan
dockage I'm just so glad that the
Supreme Court has ruled on gambling so I
can put some money on that
Thank You Jay always great for babies
Jay Bilas the moral compass of college
basketball for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]